esta es la embajada de ucrania en
washington tras la invasión rusa
diariamente recibe cientos de
solicitudes de personas que quieren ir a
luchar el ministerio de defensa
ucraniano decidió crear una legión
internacional coordinada por la
dirección de inteligencia del país
si la persona cumple con los requisitos
le damos el contacto en ucrania y la
persona o crank ya y firmó un contrato
con las fuerzas armadas de ucrania estos
no son mercenarios que vienen a ganar
dinero absoluto
eric trigger vivía en minnesota y
decidió formar parte de la legión
emprendió su viaje con algunos
compañeros y llegó a europa para
batallar en el frente a pesar de que no
tiene experiencia militar
a todo el mundo le gusta hablar de
libertad pero la libertad sólo le
pertenece a las personas que están
dispuestas a presentarse y luchar por
ella hay quienes quieren ir a curar y
salvar vidas profesionales de la salud
se preparan para ir a ucrania
si somos un equipo mixto principalmente
médicos enfermeras y psiquiatras que
tienen experiencia en tratamiento en
heridas de guerra es un nivel
desafortunado de experiencia que
nosotros tenemos y que vamos a compartir
con nuestros colegas ucranianos
hasta el momento se han apuntado más de
20.000 extranjeros provenientes de 52
países